de fait nous avaient été chassés de la
terre ça fait coût d'environ 3 1978 six
générations qu'ils ne font que sa pipe
et alors vous pensez c'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont s'arrêter et
peux vous dire tout de suite que puisque
vous avez l'intention de suivre cette
émission va falloir vous y habituer les
enfants de shadow sa peau où ça n'existe
certes depuis le temps que beaucoup de
shadow que c'était très passé et le
cosmonaute plus adverse était
passablement déglingué il avait confiant
il avait confié ouzou que produit parce
qu'ils avaient hérité de leurs ancêtres
cette vertu première indispensable au
plus noble entreprise et qu'on appelait
depuis la pommade ni quand les parents
pompe les enfants trinquent
c'est bien qu'au c'est même devenu de
nos jours un axiome de base
ce n'est qu'en pompon que vous arriverez
à quelque chose et tu aimes sulfurisé
pas bien ça vous aura pas fait là